[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con en el marco
de la conmemoración del día del medio
ambiente hablaremos de esta materia y de
los llamados que hacen diferentes
sectores de nuestra sociedad para el
cuidado de nuestro planeta entre esos
sectores están los jóvenes y por eso hoy
está con nosotros francisco ver a
manzanares quien con sólo 11 años es un
reconocido ambientalista y también es
embajador de buena voluntad de la unión
europea francisco bienvenido a france 24
gracias por acompañarnos y como ya lo
decía estamos en el marco de la
celebración del día del medio ambiente
porque esas fechas son importantes desde
su perspectiva
ahora sí es bueno muchísimas gracias
primero que todo por la habitación con
vuestro poder estar acá para con ustedes
bueno pues estas fechas son sumamente
importantes porque el ambiente y la
naturaleza en la que nos brinda como
nombre está literalmente todo la vida me
brinda los recursos naturales el planeta
tiene como un gran filtro que lo vuelve
maravilloso y magnífico que que nos
permite respirar acá y es algo que ya
nos parece normal común ya hemos vivido
pero frena sí sí sí es sorprendente
básicamente y por ello es tan importante
francisco más allá de celebrar esta
fecha hay que actuar hay que ser
responsables en el medio ambiente con el
medio ambiente nuestro día a día que es
lo que hace usted en su día a día para
defender el medio ambiente
pues yo hago muchas cosas esta es una de
las cosas que hago generar conciencia en
las personas hablando comunicando
encaminados descontando en las cosas con
noticias que se relacionan con medio
ambiente aunque acciones cotidianas
específicamente lo recicló acá en
colombia están los tres colores para
separarlos los en sólidos el negro el
blanco y el verde y siembro tengo una
planta de maravilla de limón de tomate
de cilantro ya entonces seguimos sus
cosas y néctar también francisco es
impresionante lo que usted hace para
generar conciencia usted también hace
parte de un grupo de jóvenes activistas
que se llama guardianes por la vida cuál
es el propósito de este grupo qué
función desempeña usted allí
bueno pues yo soy líder y fundador del
guardianes por la vida no siempre insp
al mente porque digamos que la mayoría
de movimientos como para bajar personas
más grandes jóvenes principalmente pero
por eso eso a uno no le permite avanzar
en que los niños podemos participar
diariamente en esas causas
medioambientales y climáticas por
supuesto y principalmente busca vivir a
la conciencia ahora estamos en colombia
argentina méxico
francisco usted tiene solamente 11 años
es una activista muy joven tiene muchos
seguidores en las redes sociales y es
reconocido en su país en colombia por
esta labor ambiental que usted está
desarrollando es importante que los
líderes jóvenes se apropien del tema del
medio ambiente y hagan escuchar sus
voces como lo hace usted a través de las
redes sociales
así es lo que es sumamente importante no
porque los jóvenes sólo seamos el futuro
de los jóvenes también considere creo
que somos el presente si somos quienes
hoy envían millones de nosotros y los
niños no también por supuesto yo todavía
no soy yo en su niño familia y así como
como yo hay muchos más niños y millones
entre ti entre millones que luchan por
estos cauces y por otras más por la
música
bueno francisco usted que le dice a esas
personas que lo comparan con negrita
thunberg esa famosa activista
medioambiental sueca
pues bueno es que este indicamos un poco
difícil comparar a veces porque digamos
el contexto en el que realizamos las
cosas es ya muy muy diferente si yo sea
obviamente colombia o suecia no tiene un
alumno de diversidad y tampoco tiene las
mismas con las mismas condiciones para
hacer activismo es decir que la
conectividad a las redes sociales es muy
mala
francisco muchas gracias por haber
estado con nosotros aquí en france 24
gracias por generar esa conciencia
dentro de los jóvenes colombianos
seguramente esto va a traer frutos en el
futuro una sociedad mucho más consciente
del cuidado medioambiental gracias por
haber estado con nosotros y haber
compartido con nosotros este punto de
vista en torno a la conmemoración del
día del medio ambiente a ustedes gracias
también por la sintonía siga con france
[Música]